hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back let's play haunted
memories now it seems that I've reached
a dead end over here what does that even
say do not cross
don't cross you a well you seem to go in
too often to Italy but I do not know
where I need to go there's a generator
in restrict B but I can't I can't even
find pages what was that I heard some
pause that all that seriously I've been
having serious trouble finding pages so
I don't know where to go what this is
fenced off what do you mean well I gotta
go around that means I gotta go through
the cave again oh boy
now I found a red fuse a really big one
to go with a red emblem the only red
emblem I remember was seeing oh yeah
okay those nothing something just shined
white in my eyes weird oh my flashlight
is almost dead oh whatever it's me it
doesn't help much anyway I don't think I
have any batteries let's forget it
I'm putting the flashlight away oh that
is rather up Oh God
I was scared by that plant that one
right there I was scared by that that's
how much of a baby I am I can't possibly
make that up I was scared by that
flippin paint what [ __ ] okay never mind
whatever that is this most that is super
derp than being scared by that statue
never mind I don't want to talk about
this
this is carry on I'm a little on edge
because slanty man is breathing down my
neck and I haven't even found anything
and I haven't been able to get to a save
so I might be a bit boned here I got to
do my spinny maneuver alright so there's
a red emblem in there I got this fuse
what does it all mean ah the pieces are
there I just can't put them together
let me try to equip this kinda way no
yeah I think there's no gas in the tank
okay so well balls balls the other
things I haven't been is up on top so
let's go to the middle area there's got
to be something maybe normal people when
they play this game they'd be well there
seems to be something in the middle area
I'm gonna go find it because it seems to
be an important location I'm completely
out of batteries or else load on my
flashlight out yeah
gives me the heebie-jeebies the hippie
Jews who were Jewish it was GB jealous
Jimmy zippers Abbas okay whatever is
gonna carry on Houston in the blind
flenderman seems to want my ass it seems
to want to caress it with his tentacles
what he's doing is somehow both alluring
and arousing but so wrong okay is this
what we're doing I seem to have entered
into a romantic relationship with the
Slenderman I never thought it would
happen to me dear Penthouse Forum I
never thought it would happen to me
let's letter man huh we're in love
tentacles are so nevermind you know what
I'm gonna stop this train train wreck
before I keep going I'm just gonna say
no absolutely not yeah my vision was
awfully bobbly there this guy can't run
for more than a few steps at a time and
he breezed like Darth Vader I think that
might be Who I am
woah woah it's dark whoa it's dark woah
dark okay
my flashlight exists that's basically
all it is it's just a small comfort
there what what is this where did I go
where am I going
woah don't don't do that to me why is it
glistening silver
oh my apples okay there's some another
path up here but it's just sheer rock
what am I supposed to do listen uh this
I want to go what are you talking about
maybe over here did I go did I come this
way or did I go this way where did you
come from weddings go where did you come
from slender you douche yeah okay no I'm
going backwards what the hell look what
I did Sam what were they all I did was
see that cheeky and the noise and he
vanished I don't know where I'm supposed
to go ah man I can't see nothing can't
see nothing I have no I don't have
batteries
oh wait over here oh okay all right it's
tucked away it's like deep in the
mountain here and gonna do spinning move
I can barely see anything as it is I
don't know how they expected me to see
that well whatever okay oh how I wish I
could see but the light has gone out
even the sky has darkened why why have
you forsaken me
everything oh there we go
I was just in the crevice I couldn't see
ah damn this game is messing with me I
swear I cannot see two inches in front
of my face
there we go that's the matter that is
gigantically bright but it's not
illuminating Jack diddly oh okay alright
okay let's just keep going keep going
what is that what is that what is that
whoa whoa that is a tower that is a
tower of epic proportions
holy crap I'll climb that in a second
I'll and there's an end to this I'm
almost Han let me go all the way down
here first see if there's something that
I need to collect but I do not know no
batteries batteries anything my
flashlight is dead literally dead de de
dead battery
no uncle wood nothing here I remember
this this used to be a page on here
somewhere okay whatever
just keep going all we can hope for all
we can hope for there is nothing else
for me here
hey battery nothing no batteries no
comfort nothing for me here only death
awaits me in the darkness what is that
whoa whoa no way
it's an axe holy crap I have an axe
you're joking me can I use that I can oh
my god I have an axe maybe this is what
I was supposed to have oh man I could
have bashed open a door or something
with this I bet I can't fight Slenderman
but I sure as crap could have done
something with this oh my god this would
have been so much more helpful oh wow
still I've seen nothing else so I'm
assuming them thank you something ooh is
that a page oh god oh my god I found a
page what does it say oh the guards have
found small groups of local media
reported snooping around a high of order
to cap them capture them to be prepared
for adaptation should prove useful
I insist all unauthorized guests are
dealt with in the same punishment from
now on so you just throw him into your
hellhole of a prison
all right let's climb this gigantic this
is gonna take forever to climb this
thing is unbelievably huge ah what did I
do
what'd I do what happened what the hell
happened you can't just do that to me
man
what happened then slend even try to
climb the stairs I don't know I don't
know Jesus how long is this thing oh no
oh man there better be something
important up here that's all I have to
say there isn't
I'm gonna be very very upset
and by very upset I'm gonna be
moderately upset and still excited about
how cool this game is it's like a
sandbox almost a sandbox of horrors and
nightmares is you never want to see ever
in your life Oh entire place oh man
boy I sure wish they could put an
elevator on this thing Oh Paulie there
was away but there is no way oh how I
wish there was a way oh man I finally
run out of steam I sprinted for a while
there hey I found it the top the tippy
top Ian there's a save point finally
save over Marga buyers awesome oh hell
yeah
maybe now even I'll even create Marc
Blair's awesome to the sequel the
awesomer okay I'm finally up here is
there anything up here worth having what
ah come on
there can't be nothing Oh literally
nothing
ha what happened you can't just do that
stop doing that you just do that there's
no Slendy man you just do it ah not
doing that
what there's a couch up here what sorry
sacks that crap had to carry this couch
up here walk
Oh whack whole whack there's a place
where I could jump off to my death I'd
be nice maybe I'll do that oh I gotta
climb all the way back down was that
really for nothing
what's that seriously for nothing oh my
god you gotta be joking me there's a red
herring if there ever was one
there was no key there's no usable there
was no page maybe it's like pages are
random
stop doing odd I'm gonna assume that's
nothing until proven otherwise not doing
that you're Zuma [ __ ] just like random
scares for no reason I thought you were
better than this thought you were better
than this game okay alright whatever
whoa whoa whoa whoa where am i oh I'm
not even close to down yet good good I
was hoping I was wishing that I was
wishing that I was the thing wishing
upon a star sorry I just been walking
Brian Regan II and stop quoting him good
God let me down to the bottom this was a
waste of my time my life oh come on
stump gets stuck let's go let's go let's
go almost there almost there almost
there almost there almost there almost
there
ah-ha I see the end good lordy Lou I was
unbelievable was a point of all that I
got a spin cuz my mouse well is a point
what dear Lord was all the point of that
okay whatever I think is back the way I
came either way I got a fire axe in a
page I'm doing better than I was before
I think this is the way I came right is
this I can't tell it's dark
is this the way I came yeah yeah it is
okay so I got I'll make the long arduous
journey back down to the normal area
good god I I originally said this wasn't
as astronomically big but they decided
to shrink it down and make it go up yeah
maybe I'm just an old man complaining
about too much
whatever but I'm just gonna get out of
here let me get out here gonna get out
of here I don't know what I want Renee
is it want from me I just gotta find
more pigs I'm on the right track bobbing
my head up and down to the beat that I
hear in my book by god yeve it oh and
actually you think distiller I shall
link flake make him go away
thinking make him go away okay think
he's going oh oh you son of a [ __ ]
talking about my butt again
and then all sudden you come barreling
through the woods like dude stiff market
buyers say but marks but okay no no you
pervert
have nothing to say to you so that
actually was a thing that was happening
before you see you can't see it anything
I need to get to the save point down
here cuz if I heard that oh that I heard
something
bird can a bird would be living in here
good a demon Slendy bird oh yeah wife
please I've been on edge for far too
long
I got that okay it's okay he's not gonna
kill me he's blocking out me from
getting to the same point that's all
he's doing
all he doing all i doing he doesn't want
me to go back I can't escape I can't go
back okay I'm fine he won't kill me if I
go back you're right it's a duplicate of
the same what nice ordering there dick
there
okay let's just calm down everybody calm
down here everybody calm your tits calm
down okay anyway actually I think I need
to stop here I don't have time to go I
don't even know where I'm going so if
you know what I need to do please let me
know in the comments below and I'll read
them so anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done I got of it I'll
let them kill me why not come at me bro
I got axe I'll chop your balls off Oh
your dad okay so anyway I got the save
anyway it don't matter so anyway thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation move it is it I've done and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye
my food
I don't happily
there's not that much
ha ha
apart oh wait go this way okay I got it
there's more chef if I a lot more